permite a luz demócratas mantener el
control del senado Katherine Cortés
mastó ganó el estado clave de Nevada
derrotando Por poco a su oponente
republicano Adam su reelección se
produce 24 horas después de la de Mark
Kelly en Arizona el ex astronauta ganó
frente a Black Masters
es fantástico estar hoy aquí al contar
nuevos votos queda claro que hemos
tenido éxito en esta misión
me siento muy honrado de que Arizona
haya depositado su confianza en mí para
representar a nuestro estado en el
senado de los Estados Unidos durante
seis años más
los demócratas tienen ahora 50 escaños
en el senado en cuanto a la cámara de
representantes el resultado es más
incierto según el presidente joeyden no
hago predicciones sobre el resultado
Pero lo que sí puedo predecir es que
estará reñido hasta el final puede que
ganemos pero solo el tiempo lo dirá en
cualquier caso La ola roja republicana
que algunos prometían no se produjo lo
que no ha ayudado en el Trump está
previsto que anuncie su candidatura a
las elecciones presidenciales 2024 el
próximo martes según un asesor cercano
el ex presidente es criticado
públicamente por los periódicos
conservadores y otras figuras
republicanas podrían hacerle sombra
entre ellas ron de santis el gobernador
de Florida reelegido por amplio margen
que tiene ambiciones presidenciales en
cualquier caso podría convertirse en un
serio rival para Donald Trump